This is TWIT.
When I first got there, I got called into this meeting in the boardroom, and Steve was there.
And I was sitting next to Chris Espinoza, you know, and I'm like, wow, what am I doing here?
But apparently Steve was reviewing everything, and he was talking about it.
And he goes, and he laid it out to us right there in that meeting.
He said, we're going to beat these people, and we're going to beat them by moving faster.
We're going to innovate them, outmaneuver them, outdeliver them.
Who was them? Microsoft?
Everybody that we had to compete with.
Everybody we had to compete with.
Everybody that thought we were going to die.
And he had a fire in his eyes, right?
He wanted to save Apple.
Oh, yeah.
And actually, he felt very strongly that Apple had screwed the pooch for the last 10 years.
And thank God they brought me back.
Right? Didn't he?
You know, I'm glad he got back, too.
it changed everything.
So I turned to Espinosa and I said,
when was the last time you were in a meeting with Steve?
And, you know, if...
Espinosa is one of the original Mac engineers.
He has a brain that's like
a machine. And he goes,
oh, it was April 13th.
And I said, so what's the difference?
And he goes, they're not trying to get rid of them.
Big difference.
Now, he was at that point the I-CEO
and they kept pretending that this is
just temporary, I'm advising.
But they had acquired Next.
You know, we've seen recently.
Well, this was actually before that.
This was even before they acquired X.
Yeah, this is when he just got back.
What, they brought him as a consultant?
I don't even know if he had taken on a specific title.
they just, they said, come in, Steve, we're dying, please help.
And changed the company.
And at that time, Apple was like a lot of companies where you had little fiefdoms,
where people were in charge of their little thing,
and they weren't working as a cohesive unit.
And Steve was a very strong King
too he thought it had to be a hole it couldn't be and he just said well you know this is where
we're going I'm sorry your stuff's going to get cut but it's getting cut if you want if you don't
want to do that fine get somebody else we're going this way and the product managers like myself
had a role to play in that mobility of turning that ship yes guys like Mitchell Weinstock who
who was the product manager for QuickTime,
masterful at marketing a technology
way beyond just him doing that.
He looked like an entire organization of 50 people.
You know, you had Richard Ford
who was handling all the network stuff.
And he was a master at running things through the system.
He could get them through the system very quickly.
and then there was Eric Zelenka who was the most one of the most amazing product managers i ever
met the guy took over Mac os 10 server and just turned that in from a raw lump of coal into this
fantastic thing he was consummate inside guy so being a product manager was like there was only
a handful there was like maybe 10 of us in the company at the time so you're at this meeting
And Steve, at this point, is he wielding?
Product manager.
Product.
Yeah.
Is Steve, at this point, wielding an axe?
Well, Steve had started wielding the axe since he got there.
I mean, every day you would hear people fall off the roof.
It'd be like, ah!
Splop!
Ah!
All day long.
Not literally, but okay.
He would work his way through, you know, it was the cluster of buildings.
But it needed to be done.
Yeah.
And the first time I met Steve, we got in a fight.
Well, this is the story I heard.
he didn't think much of what you were up to uh no it wasn't that he didn't think much of what
uh you needed to justify your existence yeah so Steve basically fired our vice president in front
of us and you know called all the product marketing into into town hall and our vp says goodbye and
And then Steve starts, you know, raving on us, telling us that we didn't know what you're doing.
You're screwing the company up.
You don't know your idiots.
It was easier when we were 100 times better than Windows.
But now that we're not, you don't know what to do.
And so I said to him, the first words I ever said to Steve were, no, you're wrong.
And he turns, spins around, and he looks at me, and he goes, and you are?
This is in Town Hall.
In Town Hall.
In front of everybody else.
Yeah.
You stood up and said, no, you're wrong to Steve Jobs.
Yeah. My first words to Steve were, no, you're wrong. And he spins around and looks at me and
says, and you are? I said, I'm Sal Sugoi I'm the AppleScript products manager. No,
you're wrong. My technology is many times better than Windows. And he goes, well, that's not what
they've been telling me. And then we just, we went at it in front of everybody. I look over
and there's my boss, like Peter Lowe, looking at me commit employee seppuku in front of everybody.
Well, what's your choice, right?
You either save, you convince him this is a great product,
or you're not going to be working there anyway.
So what Steve was doing, it turns out,
so we fought for a couple minutes,
and then he goes on to something else.
What's he saying, and what are you saying?
Give me an example.
Well, he said, you know, nobody's using this stuff.
And I said, that's absolutely wrong.
I said, all the companies are depending on this.
We use this.
All of our big customers, small customers use this.
And he goes, well, that's not what I've heard.
lying to you and so you know we just we just went at it but that's what you but you know what i bet
you he i guarantee you that's exactly what he wanted from you it was what he was looking for
he was being like this on purpose to see who in the room who believes pushed back on him yeah and
you know after that did you know that or did you see red what was it that gave you permission to
say Steve you're wrong well i figured it this way you know Apple asked me to join i might be a dog
on my square yard of dirt but you know i know every piece of that square yard and you're on my
square yard of dirt and I'm gonna bite your leg off and i know what i'm talking about and i know
what I'm talking about and he was wrong and you need to hear this and you need to hear this and
so he went on to something else and then he tested somebody else and i figured out oh he's testing
who he has to work with and everybody that fought him back stayed and the rest of the people left
right basically is how it worked and so after that he liked me yeah yeah and i would too so but
you want guys what are going to tell you the truth you don't want some schmuckers going to
tell you what you want to hear yeah and steve got automation very quickly did he oh absolutely Steve
was a ally and an advocate of automation he didn't necessarily understand all the different details
about writing the code and everything but he understood its importance and its role and why
it was necessary for customers to have that option and while he was there we got resources that we
needed consistently he made sure that we had the resources we needed to advance the technology with
each system release yes and did it got better and better it got better and
better